bonsoir philippe vardon merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france tout
d'abord notre réaction à cette
manifestation non autorisée une
manifestation de soutien aux
sans-papiers aujourd'hui il faut
remettre les choses dans leur contexte
il faut voir de quoi il s'agit en
réalité nous avons des gens qui sont
entrés illégalement dans notre pays qui
participent à une manifestation
interdite
est ce que c'est vraiment la meilleure
façon de commencer leurs relations avec
la france puisque comme ils nous l'ont
dit ils veulent leur régularisation
comme si d'ailleurs devenir français
était une sorte de droit il suffisait de
venir et puis l'eau redevient français
c'est une manifestation illégale de gens
présents illégalement dans notre pays
je vois d'ailleurs on voit les
interventions de la police mais qui sont
intervenus extrêmement tardivement
on a une manifestation de plus de 5000
personnes qui s'est déroulé pendant une
heure elle été annoncé avant même que la
police intervienne on a vu à de
nombreuses reprises et votre antenne
s'en est souvent fait l'écho beaucoup
plus de zèle de la part notamment de la
préfecture de police de paris et du
préfet l'allemand face à d'autres
manifestations
on a vu des airs beaucoup plus martiaux
la part de messieurs une aise et
castaner et là on a l'impression mais
comme souvent avec ce gouvernement d'un
pouvoir extrêmement faible d'un pouvoir
laxiste et en réalité l'intervention est
arrivés très tardivement
je demande moi ce soir à l'issue de ces
affrontements à l'issue de cette
manifestation qui a tourné à l'émeute
combien d'arrestations et puis au delà
combien d'expulsion ces gens sont
présents illégalement sur notre
territoire
ils n'ont pas le droit d'être là en
réalité ils ont encore moins le droit de
manifester cette manifestation était
interdite je crois qu'il faut en finir
avec cette faiblesse est que la france
se fasse enfin respectés alors j'adore à
votre question il ya eu 92
interpellation est exactement pourquoi
selon vous l'ol compte pourquoi selon
vous cette manifestation et elle était
maintenue alors que l'on sait que la
région ile de france et en zone orange
qu'il faut respecter certaines mesures
sanitaires on est encore en pleine en
pleine pandémie pourquoi selon vous les
organisateurs ont-ils
maintenu cette manifestation aujourd'hui
précisément ces gens sont dans une
relation de défi à la france je parle là
là tout autant de ces immigrés
clandestins qui manifestent que de tous
les réseaux de l'extrême gauche sans
frontiérisme qui s'articule autour d'eux
on a vu dans ces manifestations
des pancartes en écriture inclusive je
ne crois pas que ce soit ces clandestins
qui les ai rédigé ils sont eux aussi
quelques pas manipuler mis en action par
un certain nombre de réseaux qui
détestent notre pays qui veulent voir
c'est de dissolution de notre identité
continuer et face à ça on a un pouvoir
qui a encore une fois fait preuve de
beaucoup de faiblesses face à tout cela
fait preuve de beaucoup de faiblesses
face à l'immigration clandestine
de manière générale vous vous rendez
compte dans la capitale de notre pays
dans la capitale de la france
cinq mille sans papiers 5000 clandestins
qui manifestent bien normalement il
devrait être arrêté
conduits dans des centres de rétention
et expulser rapidement
c'est le seul message que l'on peut
avoir face à cela parce que ce
comportement n'est pas celui de gens qui
veulent faire corps avec la france qui
veulent s'intégrer s'assimiler comme
nous le défendrons rassemblement
national à notre nation ils sont dans
une agressivité qui est palpable
le premier clandestins qui intervenait à
votre antenne disait nous sommes en
colère mais en colère après qui après
nous après l'état français après les
français mais c'est les français qui
devrait être en colère
nous avons eu au mois d'avril résultant
de la crise sanitaire que nous
connaissons et du confinement 843 mille
demandeurs d'emplois supplémentaires
dans notre pays
huit cent quarante trois mille
demandeurs d'emplois supplémentaires
dans notre pays est aujourd'hui on voit
ses associations ses personnalités les
pétitionnaires professionnels qui n'ont
pour seule préoccupation que le sort de
jean qui encore une fois sont entrés
illégalement se sont maintenus
illégalement dans notre pays
mais vous peut-on imaginer cela où
peut-on imaginer cela
moi ma préoccupation elle va d'abord
assez 843 mille demandeurs d'emploi
français que l'on compte en plus depuis
ce mois d'avril
philippe vardon parmi ces sans papiers
on le sait il y a des gens qui
travaillent d'ailleurs certains ont
travaillé dans les champs pendant le
finalement pour aider les agriculteurs
qui n'avaient pas de main d'oeuvre vous
parlez de rapatriement en ce moment on
sait que les vols pour l'instant son
sont cloués au sol néanmoins que dites
vous de ce qu'a fait le gouvernement
pour ces personnes justement le premier
ministre a dit qu'il n'avait pas besoin
d'être régularisés de temporairement
alors que faire mais nous avons des
centres de rétention qui sont faits
justement pour être dans cette situation
passagère
parce que quand on est en situation
illégale dans notre pays le parcours
normal devrait être l'arrestation le
placement en centre de rétention
et puis l'expulsion quand on veut
devenir français on passe par la voie
légale
quand on veut devenir français on
démontre son envie de participer à la
vie de ce pays légalement on n'entre pas
illégalement
on ne se maintient pas illégalement ne
travaille pas illégalement et je pense
moi que ce qui d'ailleurs font
travailler ces clandestins et souvent il
faut bien le reconnaître les exploitent
les font travailler avec des salaires de
misère sont eux aussi grandement
responsable et devraient être jugés de
la même façon il y a encore une fois
huit cent quarante trois mille
demandeurs d'emplois supplémentaires
dans notre pays
depuis cette crise sanitaire c'est à eux
que ces emplois devraient aller en
priorité oui évidemment il faut d'abord
rétablir nos frontières pour nous
protéger de cette immigration
clandestine
il faut ensuite faire appliquer nos lois
expulsé ces immigrés clandestins
et puis en matière dans le poids il faut
appliquer la priorité nationale et aussi
faire la chasse aux patrons voyous qui
exploite cette misère humaine
dernière question philippe vardon cette
manifestation n'a pas vraiment été
couvertes par d'autres médias tout info
qu'en pensez vous pour quelles raisons
vous savez le plus souvent le problème
dans le traitement journalistique n'est
pas tant la tonalité du traitement que
le choix éditorial et faire le choix de
parler ou de ne pas parler d'un sujet
c'est déjà en soi le choix le plus fort
que l'on peut faire effectivement l'on
peut regretter que ce soit d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux ou bien ce soir
dans l'écran médias nationaux
cette espèce d'omerta voilà les images
que nous voyons votre antenne elles sont
choquantes et sans doute certains
pensent qu'il ne faut pas les montrer
aux français bien moi je crois qu'on a
toujours tort
ne pas dire la vérité aux français voilà
on a toujours tort de ne pas montrer les
choses telles qu'elles sont après chacun
fera son jugement sur cette situation
les français peuvent avoir des regards
divergent différents mais au moins que
nous ayons un terrain de discussion qui
soit le même et qu'il soit informé
correctement
merci beaucoup fait bar non d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rtl